yo what's going on i'm youngblood and
i'm here with buzzfeed
celeb to celebrate my album
that's coming out weird by reading your
first tweets
so i'm a bit nervous about this man
because i've seen these videos before
oh sorry but young would smile
the cutest thing to ever say thank you
bloody made me smile youngblood's lips
are phenomenal
but it's so funny man people sometimes
either love my mouth or they ate my
mouth
if like people don't get me they always
like
say he's just got such a big mouth i
mean i've got quite a big mouth like
i can fit me fist in it i got a face
full of young blood's ass this weekend
and it was marvelous where did you get a
face full of my
ass i i'm never quite sure to say ass or
arse
but i say ass would you like to see my
ass
rob i don't know whose face my ass was
in this weekend but i'm glad you found
it marvelous
literally obsessed with this man love
his music lyrics and style dream with
him all the time love you youngblood
hashtag
obsession hashtag youngblood hashtag
fantasy
love hashtag music misunderstood
well they escalated quickly youngblood
lick me please all right
but i'm such a licker provide a love
licking things
apparently when i came out of me mum
it's a weird way of putting it
when i was giving birth to the first
thing we did and my dad did was he licks
me apparently like he just licked me
head so i think that's why i like
licking things
people say i'm a lover i'm a fighter i'm
a liquor
i want youngblood's babies um thanks
not to be dramatic or anything i want
young blood to step on me
why it'll hurt i'm probably not gonna do
that
have i ever been stepped on have i been
stepped on in bed now i've never been
stepped on
maybe maybe i should try it to see what
the hype's all about just a daily
reminder that i want youngblood to rip
me open cool
youngblood radiates big energy
is it cause i'm loud i want young wood
to impregnate me
thank you i am flattered at least set me
out for dinner first yeah
is it wrong to say that i want
youngblood to rail me
and absolutely destroy me
nah i don't think that's wrong i think
that's that's nice
is anybody else thinking about a machine
gun kelly youngblood threesome except
for me
i am i'm thinking about it jeff i'm
thinking about it jeff
i want young blood to spit in my mouth
more than anything in the world i like
i'll be really honest i'm kind of into
that i want young blood to take off
i want young but to take off his
shoelaces
and choke me with them not gonna do that
because i'll probably go to prison
forever
i want you to show fish and chips in my
redacted what does that even mean
where do you want to put the fish and
chips i want your mud to shove fish and
chips in my [ __ ]
is it because i'm english very patriotic
of me in it
young bud is hot af and you cannot
change my mind on that he could tie me
up with gaffer tape
lock me in a shed and go out to the
garden for my best friend
but still say thank you that's hot i'm
kind of into it
and i just love it when people just get
mental and freaky so keep it up i
still want to find out where someone
wanted me to shove fish and chips
i love you so much man i'm youngblood
and this has been first tweets on
buzzfeed
what
you